Hace tres años recibí una llamada por una película que había realizado anteriormente...
y me ofrecían trabajar como periodista corresponsal en la Guardia Nacional de New Hampshire.
Lo pensé, me desperté en mitad de la noche.
Todos hemos pasado por esos momentos.
Estaba muy emocionada por la llamada,
pensaba que acababa de terminar una película sobre los veteranos de la II Guerra Mundial...
y me dí cuenta de que logré conocer sus historias.
Me di cuenta de que era una oportunidad única en mi vida:
Poder narrar la historia de un soldado en directo.
Esa noche me fuí a la cama muy emocionada.
No estaba muy segura de todos los detalles, pero si muy emocionada.
No eran las cuatro de la madrugada pero sí era casi medianoche...
cuando me desperté de golpe, completamente lúcida...
y tuve una idea: ¿Y si pudiera integrarme en la historia de forma virtual...
y al mismo tiempo crear un vínculo con los soldados?
¿Y si pudiera contar la historia desde adentro hacia afuera y no al contrario?
Entonces volví a llamar al Mayor Heilshorm,
Oficial en Relaciones Públicas de la Guardia Nacional de New Hampshire.
Me reconoció y entonces le dije: "¿Greg?"
A lo que el respondió: "Sí, ¿Deborah?"
Le conté mi idea y ya saben,
él es uno de los hombres más valientes del mundo,
igual que el General Blair. Él fue el que me autorizó para seguir con este experimento.
En menos de 10 días estaba en Fort Dix.
Me dió a elegir entre las unidades.
Yo elegí la Compañia Charlie, Tercera de la 172º...
de la Infantería de montaña, por dos motivos.
Primero porque eran infantería;
y segundo porque iban a estar en la base Anaconda,
así que tendrían acceso a Internet.
La condición para acceder era conseguir a soldados voluntarios.
Esto era muy importante.
Creo que cuando el Mayor H. me lo dijo...
no comprendí por completo lo que quería decir.
A lo que se refería, era que cuando llegara a Fort Dix.
debía pararme frente a 180 hombres y explicarles mi visión de las cosas.
Podrán imaginar la avalancha de preguntas que recibí.
La primera fué...
"¿Qué mierda sabés tú acerca de la Guardia Nacional?
Le conté las Guerras contra los Indios Pequot, en la Bahía de Massachusetts en 1607...
y mi respuesta se extendió nueve minutos.
Así fue como empezamos.
Ahora, me gustaría mostrarles una parte del documental.
Es como un trailer ya que obviamente está muy ocupados...
y otros no han tenido la oportunidad de verlo.
Así que vamos a ver el video,
y luego voy a coger una escena para comentarla.
¿Podemos empezar?
Pink: Este es el Sargento Stephen Pink.
Moriarty: Especialista Michael Moriarty.
Bazzi: ¿Realmente quiero ir? Probablemente no.
Soldado: Se supone que no debería hablar con la prensa.
P: Yo no soy de la prensa, ¡joder!
M: Llegó el día. Mi vida no va ser la misma.
S: ¡Esto es de verdad! ¿Están listos?
¡Venga! ¿Listo? ¡Iraq, allá vamos!
B: De vez en cuando, todo soldado quiere combatir.
Es un instinto natural.
P: Si permites que el miedo te domine...
no vas a hacer bien tu trabajo.
M: Cada vez que sales, hay ataques.
Es increíble.
B: Eh, Nestor, ¡tu culo está justo en mi cara!
S: Quinto, ¿Estamos ardiendo?
¡Hombre muerto! ¡Hombre muerto!
M: ¡Sigue así hermano! ¿Querés jugar?
Esposa de Moriarty: Para él es muy duro no tener a su padre.
M: Este niño está en el medio de una zona de guerra.
Novia de Pink: Al principio, él me decía "¡Escríbeme algo guarro!"
G. W. Bush: La nueva democracia del mundo.
M: Me están disparando.
P: No pongas 150,000 tropas allí...
para decir que están construyendo una democracia.
Soldado: Ya tenemos autoservicio en Burger King.
P: Estamos aquí para crear dinero.
M: Yo estoy de acuerdo con George Bush. No estamos allí por el petróleo.
Jon Baril: Es lo peor que me ha pasado en la vida.
P: Baril, no mires amigo.
Esposa de M: Él ya no es el mismo de antes.
M: Yo no voy a volver.
Kevin Shangraw: Se supone que estamos allá para ayudar...
y acabamos de matar uno.
Soldado: ¡El Sargento Smith está muerto! ¿El Sargento Smith está muerto?
¡Allí están! ¡Justo ahí! ¡Fuego, fuego!
Baril: Será un mejor país dentro de 20 años porque estuvimos allí.
Eso espero.
Deborah Scranton: Muchas gracias.
Una de las cosas sobre las que me gustaría hablarles...
es sobre cómo sostener una conversación en un tema difícil de tratar.
Y me gustaría contarles cierta experiencia que tuve aquí en TED.
No sé cuántos de ustedes lo sabrán,
pero entre nuestra audiencia se encuentra alguien que recientemente regresó de Iraq.
¿Paul? Vamos, ponte de pie.
Él es Paul Anthony.
Sirvió en la Marina,
y quiero contarles una pequeña historia.
Fuimos de los pocos afortunados...
que pudimos entrar a la clase con cámaras Sony y el sistema operativo Vista,
¿Bien?, entonces comenzamos a hablar.
La gente vio mi etiqueta y leyó "Cintas de Guerra",
y comenzamos a hablar de la guerra.
Empezamos a conversar con otras personas de la clase,
y la conversación siguió, y siguió.
Es decir, estuvimos allí una hora hablando.
Hubo un tema que realmente me marcó y me gustaría pedirles...
que lo piensen y tal vez me ayuden un poco.
Muchos nos sentimos muy inseguros al hablar acerca de la guerra...
y hablando de política.
Eso es porque no necesariemante vayamos a estar de acuerdo.
Tal vez la situación se vuelva incómoda.
¿Cómo hacemos para conversar abiertamente?
Así que ya saben, Paul estaba hablando y...
luego se volvió hacia Constance y dijo:
"¿Saben? Yo no tendría esta conversación si ella no estuviese aquí,
porque sé que ella me apoya".
Lo que quiero decir es que estaba nerviosa.
Como estoy acostumbrada a hacer entrevistas...
me sentí identificada con lo que James decía ayer.
Como estoy siempre detrás de cámaras,
puedo responder preguntas acerca de mi documental,
pero estar aquí y exponer durante 18 minutos es mucho tiempo para mí.
Retomando, lo que quería decir era: "Paul, me alegra mucho que estes aquí".
"Porque sé que me apoyas".
Este documental no era sobre Internet...
pero no hubiese podido realizarse sin él.
Las cintas de los soldados tardaron, de media, dos semanas en llegar desde Iraq.
Mientras tanto, nos enviábamos correos y chateábamos con los soldados.
No guardé todos los registros,
porque al principio no me dí cuenta...
que sería algo que me hubiera gustado guardar.
Fueron 3.211 emails, chats y mensajes de texto,
los que logré conservar.
La razón por la que cuantifico esta información es porque realmente nos embarcamos en una aventura mutua...
para llegar al final del mismo.
Por eso quiero mostrarles otro segmento,
y luego les contaré un poco de cómo logramos llevarlo a cabo.
Vamos a ver si podemos verlo.
Pink: Hoy es un deporte.
Queremos darle a estos insurgentes una oportunidad justa.
Por eso lo que hacemos es andar con las ventanillas bajadas.
Porque, como ustedes saben, obviamente jugamos con ventaja. Estoy bromeando.
Nunca vamos con las putas ventanillas bajadas.
Ni de broma, es muy inseguro.
¡Vaya!
Soldado: Por allá.
P: Vale, vayamos para allá.
Tengan en cuenta, estamos saliendo de Taji en este momento.
Creemos que la explosión fue justo afuera de la entrada de Taji,
ahora estamos yendo a esa posición.
Soldado: ¡Es un puto coche bomba!
Soldado: ¡Hijos de puta!
Soldado: ¡Pónganse el chaleco!
Eh, pasa sobre el maldito... sí, sí.
¡Cualquier elemento del 1-4 vayan a la entrada!
Alguacil 1-6, o cualquiera elemento de 1-4 ,
los necesitamos en la entrada de Taji ahora mismo, cambio.
Hombre: Te voy guiando.
(Voces)
Manténganse agachados. Dirígete a la derecha.
¡Coge tu mochila, coge tu mochila CLS!
(Gritos)
P: Había bajas en masa.
Probablemente 20 muertos y al menos 20 o 30 Iraquíes heridos.
P: Parecía... ya sabes,
como si alguien hubiese tirado una moneda a un tipo,
y fue como... No salía sangre de las heridas de bala.
Todo se había cauterizado,
era como si hubiese un vacío atravesando su cuerpo.
Esta es la escena del norte.
Acaban de quitar un cuerpo quemado de aquí, o más bien medio cuerpo.
No creo que haya quedado algo desde su abdomen hacia abajo.
Esto es sangre.
¿Sabes?, caminas...
y escuchas los pedazos de piel y...
eso es todo, es todo lo que queda.
Recuerdo haber inyectado tres intravenosas, haber vendando varios heridos.
Soldados sentados en la esquina de la barricada, temblando y gimiendo.
Médicos que estaban tan asustados que no podían ejercer.
Más tarde oí que en Taji no estaba permitido dar tratamiento a heridos Iraquíes.
Pueden trabajar por unos centavos en los puestos de paso, pero no pueden morir allí.
Tienen que morir fuera.
Si alguno de los médicos incompetentes me hubiera ordenado dejar el tratamiento...
le hubiera cortado la garganta ahí mismo.
21 horas, y es sólo nuestro escuadrón...
repasando en nuestras mentes lo que pasó hoy...
queramos hacerlo o no.
Reportera: Más violencia en Iraq.
Dos suicidas en coches bomba dejan ocho Iraquíes muertos y docenas de heridos,
cerca a una base de la coalición al norte de Baghdad...
P: Salimos en las noticias.
Me sentí explotado y orgulloso al mismo tiempo.
Ya perdí la fe en los medios,
son una broma de la que prefiero burlarme en vez de formar parte de ella.
Debería agradecerle a Dios salvar mi afortunado culo.
Voy a hacer eso, y luego me voy a hacer una paja.
Porque estas páginas huelen a Lindz...
y no va a haber tiempo para masturbarse mañana.
Otra misión a las 06:00.
Deborah Scranton: Ahora... Gracias.
Cuando dije que iba a tratar de contar la historia desde adentro hacia afuera, en vez de desde afuera me refería a...
parte que de lo que dijo Chris tan elocuentemente en su introducción tiene que ver con esta fusión.
Es una nueva forma de intentar crear un documental.
Cuando conocí a los soldados, diez de ellos aceptaron llevar cámaras,
y al final, en total, 21 terminaron filmando.
Cinco soldados filmaron a tiempo completo.
De ellos, presentamos tres en el documental.
Aprendí sobre Taji gracias a un correo que me envió Steve Pink.
También adjuntó una foto del cuerpo quemado cerca del coche.
El tono del correo era,
ya sabes, obviamente había sido un día muy duro.
Y vi en mi ventana del chat que Mike Moriarty estaba en la base.
Entonces le hablé y le dije:
"¿Mike, podrías por favor ir a entrevistar a Pink?"
Porque lo que se pierde muy comunmente es...
algo que los militares llaman "en caliente".
Es esa entrevista inmediata justo después de algúna mision. Y, como ya saben,
si se deja pasar un tiempo...
la historia se suaviza y pierde fuerza.
Para mí, eso es algo valioso.
Era necesario para poder
compartir la experiencia completa con ustedes.
Los montajes más famosos...
eran los de la cámara en la ametralladora...
y la de el salpicadero del Humvee.
Terminamos instalando cámaras en la mayoría de Humvees.
De esta forma pueden ver todo como en tiempo real.
La entrevista que vieron es la que Mike realizó...
24 horas después de lo sucedido.
La escena donde Steve Pink está leyendo su diario...
se grabó cinco meses después de que regresara a casa.
Yo sabía que el escribía en su diario, pero era algo muy, muy privado.
Y bueno, uno se gana la confianza de alguien,
especialmente mientras se filma un documental, a través de la relación que se sostiene.
No fue hasta después de seis meses de que volviera...
que decidió leerme su diario.
La parta del telediario lo incluí para tratar de mostrar...
que los medios tratan de hacer lo mejor que pueden...
de acuerdo a sus limitaciones.
Pero todos hemos oído varias veces
a soldados Estadounidenses diciendo:
"¿Por qué no hablan de las cosas positivas que hacemos?"
Este es un ejemplo perfecto.
Dos escuadrones pasaron el día entero fuera de la base, el escuadrón de Pink fue uno de ellos.
Ellos no tenía que salir de la base.
No había soldados heridos fuera.
Se pasaron el día entero intentando salvar vidas Iraquíes.
Iraquíes que trabajan en los puestos.
Cuando oigan a soldados quejándose,
eso es de lo que se están quejando.
Y el hecho de que hayan compartido esto me parece un regalo maravilloso.
Es como un vínculo.
I cuando hablo de esa polaridad, me llueven tantas preguntas...
y cada uno sostiene su punto de vista.
Parece como si no quisieran oír sobre el tema.
O escuchar, ni si quiera intercambiar ideas.
Yo soy tan apasionada como cualquier otra persona, pero...
así como varios oradores han hablado de su preocupación por el mundo,
mi preocupación se basa en que tenemos que tener estas conversaciones.
Y tenemos que estar dispuestos a sentirnos incómodos.
Porque creemos que ya lo sabemos todo,
pero tenemos que ser un poco más abiertos para poder saber.
Nuestras opiniones están como muy desconectadas.
Creo que deberíamos tratar de llegar a un acuerdo.
Voy a compartir una historia.
A menudo me preguntan...
cuáles fueron los momentos más especiales de mi trabajo en este documental.
Inevitablemente durante las proyecciones.
Estoy segura que todos ustedes dan alguna charla.
A menudo hay personas que se acercan porque quieren hacer más preguntas.
Y por lo general las primeras preguntas son,
"¿Que clase de cámaras utilizó?"
Esa clase de cosas.
Pero casi siempre hay algunos que se quedan hasta el final...
y me he dado cuenta de que siempre son soldados.
Esperan hasta que todos los demás se hayan ido.
Para mí, una de las historias más profundas que compartieron conmigo...
se convirtió en mí historia, fue...
y para los que no han visto el filme, no es un adelanto,
es que los accidentes civiles son muy comunes.
En particular, en los que la gente se para en frente de un Humvee y son atropellados.
En el filme, hay una escena donde una mujer Iraquí es atropellada.
Un soldado vino y se paró en frente de mí, muy cerca.
A un pie de distancia.
Era un tipo alto.
Me miró y yo sonreí.
Entonces sus ojos se comenzaron a llenar de lagrimas,
y no parpadeaba.
Y dijo: "Mi artillero estaba regalando dulces".
Y yo supe lo que me iba a decir.
El artillero estaba regalando dulces.
Acostumbraban a regalar dulces a los niños.
A menudo los niños se acercaban demasiado.
Y él dijo: "Yo maté a un niño".
"Soy padre, tengo hijos".
"No he sido capaz de decírselo a mi esposa".
"Tengo miedo de que piense que soy un monstruo".
Yo, por supuesto, lo abracé.
Y le dije: "Todo va salir bien".
Y el dijo: "Voy a traerla a ver su documental".
"Y después se lo voy a decir".
Cuando hablo de esa desconexión...
no es sólo por las personas que no conocen a un soldado,
lo cual obviamente ocurre.
No es como durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial; había un frente en la guerra y otro frente en casa.
Todos estaban involucrados.
Ahora uno se puede pasar días sin sentir que estamos en guerra.
Y a menudo oigo a gente decir.
Gente que tal vez sabe que hice esta película:
"Estoy en contra de la guerra, pero apoyo a los soldados".
Entonces yo les pregunto:
"Bueno, eso está muy bien. ¿Que estás haciendo?"
"¿Estás de voluntario en alguna oficina de ayuda a veteranos?"
"¿Vas a visitar a alguien?"
"¿Cuando te das cuenta que tu vecino ha estado allí, te quedas a charlar con él?"
"No necesariamente a preguntar, ¿pero solo a charlar?"
"¿Haces donaciones a alguna organización de beneficencia?"
Ya saben, como el maravilloso trabajo que está haciendo Dean Kamen.
Pero también hay organizaciones donde se pueden ayudar con ordenadores para soldados heridos.
Creo que es para mí un desafío...
el empezar a materializar el apoyo que profesamos, ¿no?
¿Eres amigo de algún veterano?
¿Realmente te importa?
Quisiera decirles que tengo esperanza. Y que me gustaría pedirles algo.
Por favor, echen una mano.
Denles un abrazo sincero.
Muchas gracias.